[Music]
words and actions have consequences
if you do something wrong you often pay
for it in some way
some call it cancel culture but i call
it
that's what your ass gets
[Music]
recently in norfolk virginia a police
officer named william kelly contributed
25 dollars
to a legal defense fund for kyle
rittenhouse the terrorist
charged with killing two people during
last year's black lives matter protests
when kelly's donations came to light he
was fired
and that's what joe asked gets you out
here giving that kid money like he's
part of an improv troupe
trying to get to a comedy festival he
doesn't need the money and
neither does that improv group cause two
of the people on this team are gonna
date and then have a nasty breakup
the rest will have to decide whose side
they're on and
they'll all quit the team after they
can't find a time they can all rehearse
also when this cop donated money to that
gofundme
he checked remain anonymous but he used
his work
email from the police department
what in the wet bandits were you
thinking
you used your work email was i'm a cop
at hotmail.com
taken you wanted to remain anonymous
because you knew
you were on some old [ __ ] just cut
out the middleman
and wear an i'm with racist t-shirt
racists are evil but they sure aren't
smart moving on
now i mentioned this story earlier but
it's worth diving into
a new york man was arrested recently for
participating in the capitol riots
after he bragged about being there on
the dating app bumble
that's what joe asks gets has this man
not heard of screenshots
receipts aren't just those long sheets
of paper you get at cvs
also what kind of weird flex is this
i did storm the capital i made it all
the way to statuary hall
statuary hall who does he think he's
hitting on a museum docent
for those of you who don't know bumble
is a dating app where
you swipe right if you're interested in
the person which begs the question
who swiped right on this he looks like
wolverine just gave up
he looks like wolverine beat up
wolverine
also another that's what joe ask gets
goes to the lady who saw this picture
and thought
ooh break me off a piece of that [ __ ]
chat bar
who were the people she swiped left on
she's the type of person who goes to a
restaurant and says i'll have your
finest grease trap
lady you deserve better and you should
love yourself more
next up in a recent senate judiciary
committee hearing
louisiana senator john neely kennedy
asked former gubernatorial candidate and
queen of the south stacey abrams to list
the provisions
she thought were racist in georgia's new
voting bill the results were
exactly what you would expect they would
be give me a list
of the provisions that you objected
i object to the provisions that remove
access to the right to vote
it shortens the federal runoff period
from nine weeks to four weeks
okay it restricts the time a voter can
request and return an absentee ballot
application
right it requires that a voter have a
photo identification
or some other form of identification
that they're willing to surrender
in order to participate in absentee
ballot
process it eliminates over 300 hours of
dropbox availability
it bans nearly all out of precinct votes
it restricts the hours of operation i
get the idea i get the idea
that's what your ass gets you really
tried it
you actually thought stacy abrams
wouldn't be prepared
this woman is the definition of prepared
she makes a swiss army
knife look like a pair of child proof
scissors and
you know you messed up when this is your
only comeback
get the idea i get the idea yeah i bet
your ass gets the idea
i hope you learned a lesson senator
kennedy but you probably
didn't because you can't teach an old
white racist new tricks
and finally last week the fbi searched
rudy giuliani's home
as part of an investigation into whether
giuliani broke lobbying laws
when he was trump's personal lawyer
that's what joe asked gets
my question is why did this take so long
it's not like giuliani is a lex luthor
level
mastermind donald trump and rudy
giuliani are like pinky in the brain
except
they're both pinky the fbi will probably
find evidence in a folder on giuliani's
computer
marked evidence personally i don't get
why giuliani is protecting trump so much
anyway
trump still hasn't paid rudy's legal
fees for his failed lawsuits to
overthrow the elections
i mean takashi 6-9 snitched for less
so here's to rudy being the rudy of dumb
criminals
a very small man who defies the odds and
finally makes it
to jail call it cancel culture or
whatever you want but
the truth is actions have consequences
and if you play stupid games you win
stupid prizes
this has been that's what your ass gets
[Music]
you